every day happening but it happen it
goes and going brothers welcome back to
the Charis Flores probably with one of
the most impressive free horror games I
played in a long time let's keep playing
oh god that double spade double fake
Jennifer nobody that kid really though
no with it
thank kick Oh more light wonderful god
that was so [ __ ] scary it reminds me
of Evil Dead when she comes out of that
the remake when she comes out of the
swamp it's [ __ ] weird man how do I
get in brothers I want to get into the
cool clubs but I don't have a VIP God
you think I being the most subscribed
[ __ ] would help you out but no alright
water again fire that's it really
Wow I'm not impressed oh [ __ ] there it
is all right I'm going for it
yo to the hole to Dubrow we got her bone
great so cliff down there I don't think
we should go down there
or should we oh well I don't have a
choice now someone [ __ ] pushed me oh
we have to go down here oh that is wrong
in my falling actually it's never wrong
in your thong oh god oh god oh god well
decide
deaf and suffering that's what it is
that's what we like wait I know this
place
aah aah I stubbed my toe
somewhere a passage open fantastic we've
been here before
well I don't know which passage I
haven't really tried out that many you
know what let's check out the pooper the
pooper has always been the answer I
loved Boober no you did not just do that
Oh first jump-scare ever Oh God last
checkpoint my god and my [ __ ] god
genius genius ah [ __ ] it scared me so
[ __ ] much all right I guess I guess
it makes sense that the passages here oh
god what is that does that mean we went
through the passage now we're back here
by the silo [ __ ] God what is that stop
[ __ ] hell Oh Oh God
safety first god dammit I suck so much
[ __ ] you my god there's no way around it
really oh right in the titty alright you
know what okay
you don't like me I don't like you but
that doesn't mean we have to fight in
space and time and stuff alright cool
nailed it ha trees can't hurt me I'm a
man with feelings okay God tell me why
you had to do that shall we
okay I'm not sure if this is the passage
at all you know what I'm actually quite
sure that it isn't at all
but sometimes in life you just gotta
take a chance take a chance towns to
catch an ten F oh boy
an apple are you hungry eat the apple
well thank you read Tex I was hungry
um nom nom nah this is no white I love
snow white I hope I get oh god I'm gonna
hop it I despise it me why did I trust
that evil text of course okay
that one I expected but let's be honest
I just wanted to check it out hey maybe
I would get like super powers and
[ __ ] fly away I don't know I would
say dying in a forest like this when
someone is stalking you I'd say a dying
from an apple is pretty [ __ ] good
okay I wouldn't mind that at all you
know what [ __ ] you Apple and I'm gonna
eat you so wait it no I'm angry
[ __ ] you oh god oh god no no more killer
trees okay I'm done with you I'm a man
I'm dead what happened okay so I made it
through we're progressing [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah what's up [ __ ] that's my rap
song that's all that oh that's
everything it's called what's up [ __ ]
I want to be a rapper one day I think I
have all the potential
Oh God oh god it's so [ __ ] thick no
no I can't
I'm sorry this has been very scary so
far but this is [ __ ] too much no no
what is that what the [ __ ] are you don't
look in that red light got it [ __ ]
got it thank you thank you very much
you're so [ __ ] kind alright here we
go
don't look into that ass ready for some
PAS come at the canola Hindley birthday
okay we're almost we almost got it
almost got it go go go go go go go take
it take it
Jason Jason we got it we got it we're so
[ __ ] dead right now though that's the
problem it's the problem with the hollom
I spoke a word of English and I think
I'm that I think I'm that I think I'm
that Bruce I think as she's up my ass
right now I think she's tickling it I
think she's smelling it I don't want to
know what she's doing with it right now
that feels good actually
oh okay let's okay we're at we're
[ __ ] at we're [ __ ] out we were
[ __ ] out of here we're so [ __ ]
done with this place I have never been
done her with any place in my entire
life except like that one time when I
hug Oprah I was not done then I wanted
to stay forever and
and in my dreams then I woke up and
knife was not that's nearly as good now
what's my climax that was my high point
see I'm
I wish I could go back the same [ __ ]
way but I can't this game is a [ __ ]
challenge man
oh god you [ __ ] [ __ ] get a job get
up do something for society god dev
every [ __ ] horror game that is all
I'm saying
am I the only one who sees this huh I
can't be the only one this is ridiculous
you know what once they have world
domination don't come to me okay
oh god somewhere a passage at open I
want to know where it's specifically cuz
it's a pretty [ __ ] big game you know
alright so we can I think is this where
the [ __ ] Apple [ __ ] was okay you
know what are you hungry no I'm not a
mr. Apple not hungry actually I am
hungry thank you for asking but I'm that
doesn't mean I'm gonna eat you go
alright might be here who knows these
days is that another one I always say
did it oh it's a teddy hi teddy you're
gonna dab here I think oh thanks teddy I
was gonna ice for some [ __ ] pep talk
but I guess I'll go somewhere else
God rude thank you what's the poop this
is literally my nightmare I'm really
hungry - I could eat it oh god what is
that Teddy you're gonna dad head shut up
you don't know me we just met you can't
just say [ __ ] like that just reindeer
God have some [ __ ] thought for your
baby wait what
uh okay let this be the final [ __ ]
piece and I will be so you know what why
do they tease me like that that is not
funny
keep in laughs this game is really
[ __ ] good more [ __ ] barrels of
course they're the ones who set this
[ __ ] trap for me I [ __ ] owe you
ask you [ __ ] my god the scarce in this
game are so good
I give surely I can kind of anticipated
and when it comes to still scares me but
not the air thank God don't trick me to
go to space
oh god he did but Edgar was part of this
too that little [ __ ] please feed be
over soon just wanted to be over all my
subscribers they do subscribing if they
got it save it's a flare vibrating sexy
boga oh no oh no dude look at her I'm
backing up backing up backing up back no
you know what no it's fine okay it's a
gate that means we exit something
doesn't it
Oh more paths [ __ ]
alright and going left first Wow Wow
great I love those sounds without
loading the forest up the sounds when
I'm all more paths Wow you know what I
was just singing to myself
more paths that'd be great right [ __ ]
now right about [ __ ] now I would like
some more [ __ ] paths please and the
air is delivered oh my god I'm so happy
so very [ __ ] happy right now so happy
candy sky looking up and [ __ ] happy I
am
oh great oh great what do we got here oh
god a creepy [ __ ] house
no what is that more arm
oh no oh god I can move oh god oh god oh
god I don't see anything I don't like
this what am I hello hello I'm a I'm a
nice person you know you
it's so dark what happened it sounds
like I'm out oh yeah my oh god I did it
me Oh
oh boy oh boy that was fun that was
really really really really really fun
fun fun fun fun lookin forward to that
weekend
never gonna go [ __ ] go there again
never gonna [ __ ] good okay yeah what
I love life I want to live I want to
have little babies a little pony paid
cute babies Oh God if you hear [ __ ]
noises it said Gary that's one point
that out probably me - honestly you know
I'm not gonna fall for the pooper trick
again that's for [ __ ] sure
hello it's a dead cow in here huh stone
I got enough stone [ __ ] yet we're gonna
save that [ __ ] ass and we're gonna go
to Disneyland kids every kid needs to
experience this new line hi there hi
there I see you match my house [ __ ] me
actually don't please kiss [ __ ] so
creepy
I can't even react to it anymore like I
just got into this [ __ ] weird
translate where I'm just in space oh she
was there I didn't see it last time oh
god she's a mean hole oh god I saw it
again alright you know what
she's in the kitchen I get it she wants
to be alone in the kitchen where is she
where the [ __ ] is she
oh god what is happening what does
happen Oh is she will see come in
don't come in come alone I don't have
any tampons hi
well you're not trying to save you right
oh god I can't take this oh come on
hi I'm just gonna go out no all right
pres sorry but you were asleep now watch
that damn skit hope you enjoy watching
they were like as always if you did I
really appreciate it a house pulls out
and it ends stuff
I appreciate nonetheless I press see you
tomorrow love you